I heard about a program young officers
trained to Deus and manipulate color
sparrows I went to film school graduated
in 91 and I ended up kind of lucking
into the world of music videos which
then led to commercials and then finally
to feature films my latest film is a
movie called red Sparrow starring
Jennifer Lawrence and it tells the story
of Jennifer Lawrence's character
Dominica yova who is a principal dancer
with the bull joy and she's horribly
injured during one of her performances
and she has a creepy uncle that works
for the modern version of the KGB and he
draws her into the world of espionage
against her well the government gave me
no choice
die or become a sparrow it's a very
tough distressing situation and making
sure that we maintained that tone was
really important to me so it's actually
a quite intense and quite a violent ride
there's a similarity with most of my
movies and that I'm really attracted to
stories about very isolated lonely
people and survival-type journeys often
spy movies are very political or they're
kind of mission and tech based and this
one is more emotional it allows the the
lead to be I think a little more
relatable the cinematographer wrote
Sparrow is yo Willems who I've worked
with for years and years now and he did
my Hunger Games movies with me those
films had a very specific aesthetic
there was a naturalism to them in terms
of natural light and sort of
naturalistic colors we wanted to do
something very different this time
the color palette itself is really
dictated by the locations we never shot
anything on a soundstage we decided to
shoot it much more formally so that the
camera is staying a lot wider and
shooting with much more symmetry because
of the use of architecture especially
the brutalist and socialist architecture
that we got in
this is what you were meant to do I'm
just such a huge fan of IMAX versions of
my movies I'm in IMAX right now looking
at the the laser version and the xenon
version and it's just unbelievable it's
so fantastic because it's just a
completely different experience to come
in here and see it on the screen with
this quality and the laser projection
you just see things that you haven't
seen all along and suddenly you're
noticing details and the work that's put
into the movies can truly be appreciated
in an environment like this it's like
seeing the movie brand-new again